in Genesis 1 God said let us make man
our image after our likeness so he's
talking to someone who he's going to
involve in creating and that's not
Angels because the angels Don't create
so is he talking to Josh no that's uh
that's it's it's it's not true because
involing no hold on a second involving
some involving them in creation does not
mean that they're actually going to
create
themselves sorry you want to bet it says
let us make man and arage after our
likeness there's no need to talk in the
plural let us make man in our image and
our likeness if God Alone is creating
unless there's someone else involved in
the creation so don't give me a post
Hawk explanation deal with unless unless
it is teaching us um the uh the the
lesson that a leader should always
consult with those beneath them even
even if those beneath them are not
actually going to take take part in the
action don't give me your copot rinic
interpret I
know can you argue with it AR yes I'm
going to argue with very easily go ahead
because in Genesis 2:7 I'm going to show
you who the other entity was that God
used to create man be patient take it
easy I'm not your rabbis who give this
lame excuse I know what you're going to
say I know you're going to say the voice
what is the breath of life that God
breathe into the nostrils of man what's
the Breath of Life is the Breath of Life
what's the breath of life it's it's the
soul no right he breaths in the soul no
it comes in no the Breath of Life is the
breath that makes man alive
yeah and that and that is the soul no
that is the Spirit hold on Josh let me
show you it's the soul I'm gonna use
your own books not me no it's the spirit
here I'm going to show you here you go
from your own tanak I didn't use the
Christian Bible who created man the
spirit of God made me and the breath of
the almighty keeps me alive so this is
Hebrew parallelism see if you know
Hebrew parallelism because I don't know
if the rabbis taught you that yet in the
second line the almighty corresponds to
who in the first line God because God is
the almighty oh good so the breath in
the second line responds to who in the
first line Spirit you just destroyed
your case and proved mine so the breath
is the spirit good job Josh when when it
says in Genesis 2 and go and and and he
blew into his nostrils the uh the the
the soul of life it doesn't say so dude
stop saying Soul it says breath nishish
means Soul no that word there wasn't
we're not talking about Nish we're
talking about the breath of life that's
not what it says
and he blew and he
blew in his
nostrils what is Nish lexically is the
soul wait wait wait wait read the
lexican hold on I don't the lexic says
breath spirit and soul and also puff
wind anger vital breath divine
inspiration intellectual and animal and
then here in Deuteronomy 2016 what's the
word
here you shall not allow anything
anything that that's very it's a very
silly
translation translated anything that
what any anything that has a soul you
shall not no you shall not let live any
Soul that's what it that's it's a silly
translation right okay on it is a silly
translation take it easy bro wait so how
did Rashi uh translate it and he
breathed into his nostrils the soul of
no take it take it easy in Genesis 2
these translations are all bad we're
going to go with yours Genesis 2 do you
agree that in Genesis 1 the spirit
played a role in creation played a role
yeah right here this right here the the
only that that yeah I mean he was
hovering over the spirit of God was
hovering over the do you agree okay do
you agree that in Genesis to it's
expanding on Genesis 1 it's it's fitting
fitting in the details of Genesis 1 and
do you agree that in Genesis 2 the god
of Genesis 1 is Hashem because you say
has of Genesis okay so now what I want
to ask you to consistency where do you
find the spirit in Genesis 2 what role
does he play in Genesis 2 he's not
mentioned I didn't ask just like you
believe genesus is an expansion of
Genesis 1 and therefore it's filling out
the details can you show me where the
spirit is mentioned and the specific
role he plays in the creation of man
because job 33:4 says the spirit of God
have made me but according to you that's
not Genesis 126 so don't do the tap
dance because when God said let us make
man that wasn't the spirit and the
breath is not the spirit so where did
job 334 get that the spirit of God made
man where do you find that in Genesis 1
and2 because it's hearkening back to
Genesis 1 and two I want you and Rashi
to bail yourself out of this one so
people understand what I'm saying let me
show you the verse again unless you're
saying job made it up okay even a blind
man can say that job 33:4 has in mind
Genesis 1 and Genesis 2 but according to
you Genesis 2 the breath of life should
be the soul of life not breath because
you want to tap Dan that's okay I'll tap
dance with you and Rashi I like that I
need to lose weight so now where do you
find in Genesis 1:2 that the spirit of
God made man don't appeal to Genesis
1126 because you just said God wasn't
speaking to the spirit so where does it
say in your
Torah the spirit made man show it to me
from Genesis 1 yeah and since you don't
like the fact that was translated breath
I'm going to show you Psalm 3 let me go
toad okay now you want to see where the
spirit created the Stars okay to prove
my point that the Breath of Life is the
spirit that comes out not the soul of
man because I'm going to ask you another
question but see I told you I'm going to
let Rashi to help you to refute me so I
can take both you and Rashi at the same
time hold on I've uh I've had a look
I've consulted the I've consulted the
Mal which is another one of our
commentaries and I'm going to agree with
you I'm going to agree with you um that
that the specific aspect of of God that
created man was um was the uh was the
the spirit of God Al I was right after
after 15 minutes of wasting my time I
was right I had to it first I hadn't
come across that do you know God was
speaking to the spirit no God wasn't
speaking to the spirit who did he say
let us make man to let us make man then
not you're not GNA find that in any of
our commentaries that God spoke to the
spirit I know I'm not gonna find it in
your commentar because
you're okay all right okay well guys
after 20 minutes to waste my time he
said I was right about the spirit creat
okay now my friend who made the host of
heaven what's the word breath don't tell
me it's
because I know what it is but I want you
to tell me what is it there say it again
and the came out of what his mouth the
breath of his mouth just like the breath
came out of God's mouth that he blew
yeah oh and you don't see that the
breath of the spirit
then yeah with the breath of his mouth
all the host yeah okay but hold on hold
on no no that's not my point you wasted
20 minutes of my life and I'm not
getting younger that's okay hold on so
when it says in Genesis 2:7 when God
breathed the breath of life that breath
that came out of him I said that's the
spirit that gives life you go no no the
soul so now it says that the ru comes
out of his mouth isn't that also where
the breath comes out from God's mouth I
mean based on this there's the breath
coming out of his mouth the comes from
his mouth but it says so now you can't
play the game saying it's meaning Soul
so now if the comes out of his mouth
then when God breathes what is he
breathing out of himself he's he's
breathing the breath out of himself what
is that breath here buddy the breath of
his mouth so you just admit R is what
say it again R means what breath only
breath we're gonna play that game it
means both oh so you just now help me
prove that what God breathes out of his
mouth is the very R and spirit so why'
you waste 20 minutes of my time when you
now agreed with me well because I
haven't come across this argument before
that's why oh okay